d'ici 2040 il n'y aura plus assez d'eau
des milliards d'humains en Macron c'est
du moins ce que prétend l'université
d'arus au Danemark mais est-ce que tout
ça est vrai sommes-nous vraiment à
quelques dizaines d'années de
l'écroulement de nos civilisations on va
voir ce qu'on disait la science et les
études contradictoires pour déterminer
quand seront épuisés les ressources les
plus importantes de l'humanité quel est
le minerai qui sera épuisé en premier
transformer le plomb en or le rêve des
alchimistes aujourd'hui c'est une
réalité on sait en faire grâce aux
accélérateurs de particules
malheureusement c'est bien trop coûteux
pour être rentable du moins aujourd'hui
tout changera en 2075 à partir de ce
stade l'extraction d'or devrait
s'arrêter alors qu'il en reste dans les
sols 1,6 quadrillion de tonnes
exactement dans le noyau de la Terre
impossible à atteindre depuis
l'Antiquité seul 244000 tonnes d'or ont
été découvertes et 75 ont déjà été
extraits le problème c'est qu'on s'est
déjà bien détecté les filons d'or on
peut remercier Gustave trouver
l'inventeur du détecteur de métal avant
ça les techniques étaient plus
rudimentaires par exemple le changement
de couleur du sol les roches les plus
vives en Australie une entreprise a
localisée indépods grâce à des nids de
termites tellement qu'elle contenait des
métaux l'or est comme le pétrole c'est
une ressource non renouvelable une fois
qu'on aura tout extrait il faudra un
temps phénoménal pour en revoir des
milliers d'années plus tard car ils ne
se forment pas sur terre mais provient
de débris d'étoile morte d'une explosion
d'énergie incommensurable en grande
partie pendant le Big Bang l'or arrive
donc chez nous par des astéroïdes pour
le pétrole c'est plus simple il faut
attendre que les matières organiques des
sols se dégradent pour reformer de
nouveaux stocks c'est long mais faisable
en quelques millions d'années il nous
reste 1,6 millions de barils de pétrole
à extraire mais avec 35 milliards de
barrés consommés par an on ne tiendra
que 47 ans avec ses réserves si la
France se la joue solo il y a peut-être
moyen qu'on en profite un peu plus
longtemps en Guyane et à Mayotte on a
trouvé des réserves équivalentes à plus
de 33 milliards de baril de quoi tenir
55 ans alors on a décidé de ne pas les
exploiter en attendant si la fin du
pétrole oblige à adapter toute une
économie imaginez pour l'or une
ressource essentiel à la technologie
moderne vos ordinateurs tablette ou
téléphone ne peuvent pas fonctionner
sans mais aussi les prothèses cardiaques
les traitements pour le cancer les
nanotechnologie on pourrait penser qu'il
suffirait de recycler lors de nos vieux
appareils électroniques comme certains
le font déjà sur internet mais non on
est obligé d'utiliser des produits très
toxiques pour récupérer quelques
poussières d'or autant se tourner vers
les bijoux c'est plus simple l'avantage
c'est qu'on stocke déjà de l'or en
grande quantité dans les banques ça nous
laisse un point de secours si nos
gisements venaient à s'épuiser même les
pays les plus pauvres en ont au moins
une centaine de tonnes en réserve reste
alors à savoir si ces mêmes banques
accepteront de céder leurs réserves et
contre quoi autre métal autre problème
peut-être le plus important de
l'histoire humaine le cuivre à peine 5
millions c'est le nombre de tonnes de
cuivre exploitables qu'il nous reste
c'est un métal qui a des propriétés
vitales très bon conducteur
d'électricité deux chaleurs résistant à
la corrosion facilement malléable et en
plus il ne coûte pas cher au-delà de sa
praticité technique il excelle dans les
médicaments antibactériens et
anti-inflammatoires c'est pas pour rien
que c'est les métaux les plus utilisés
au monde et ça n'a pas d'hier déjà en
8000 avant Jésus-Christ durant
l'Antiquité on s'en servait pour
fabriquer des sculptures des bijoux ou
des outils imaginez un monde sans cuivre
c'est presque un retour à l'âge de
pierre d'ici 2060 on parle d'une fin des
gisements naturels heureusement le
cuivre a une capacité spéciale c'est la
ressource la plus réutilisée au monde
c'est quasiment un métal infini il est
100% recyclable il suffit de le faire
fondre pour pouvoir de nouveau le
réutiliser 60% de la totalité du cuivre
et recycler aujourd'hui ne vous
réjouissez pas trop vite une fois que
tout le cuivre aura été extrait nous ne
pourrons compter que sur nos propres
stocks chaque gramme gaspillé sera perdu
pour toujours un autre muret qui
inquiète c'est le diamant déjà en 2020
93% de la production mondiale de
diamants provenait de seulement 7 pays
dont la Russie le Canada l'Australie ou
l'Afrique du Sud contrairement aux idées
reçues le diamant est majoritairement
utilisé dans la recherche pour sa
résistance incroyable seul 20% sont
utilisés dans la joaillerie s'il n'y a
plus de diamant on perd considérable de
nos technologies outils de coupe tête de
forage ou encore coiffe de missiles plus
les années passent et plus la demande
augmente ce qui oblige les extractions
de grandes quantités en 2017 c'est 5% de
la production qui chutaient en 2020 on
atteint les 20% cette chute avait
pourtant déjà été anticipé le cartel
d'ibirs un des gros de l'industrie du
diamant en Afrique du Sud avaient
annoncé en 2014 que nous ne pourrai plus
subvenir à la demande il faudra trouver
des nouvelles technologies majeures pour
combler le manque un problème que nous
ne pouvait pas prévoir c'est la guerre
dans les sept plus gros producteurs se
trouvent la Russie qui détient 29% de la
production mondiale à elle toute seule
depuis mars les prix du marché ont
augmenté de 20% en réponse sous sanction
heureusement la chimie moderne a permis
de comprendre une chose le diamant c'est
juste un long enchaînement d'atomes de
carbone qui se forme dans des conditions
bien spécifiques pression allant jusqu'à
6 milliards de Pascal 60 000 fois notre
pression atmosphérique une température
dépassant les 1700 degrés il ne manque
plus qu'une éruption volcanique pour
faire remonter dans les zones
exploitables ces conditions elles font
en réalité du diamant une pierre presque
inépuisable car la croûte terrestre
réunit toutes ces conditions mais il ne
faut pas se leurrer on parle de 50 à 70
volcans actifs chaque année dans des
zones difficilement exploitables on
s'est aussi maintenant créer des
diamants de synthèse grâce aux
découvertes de Tracy hall un physicien
américain ça permettra peut-être de les
remplacer dans les années à venir mais
est-ce qu'on arrivera en produire assez
pour la demande d'ici 5 à 50 ans
disparaîtra les gisements d'un diom de
germanium d'argent ou de zinc entre 100
et 1000 ans pour les réserves
d'aluminium d'uranium de phosphore déjà
en 2025 on sera à court de lithium en
2030 pour le cobalt en 2050 pour le
platine certaines de ses ressources sont
renouvelables ça ira mais pour d'autres
faudra s'adapter trouver des
alternatives justement j'aimerais vous
parler d'alternative sur votre façon de
naviguer sur Internet à plusieurs
occasions on a pu vous présenter notre
sponsor Nord VPN savez-vous à quel point
un VPN peut vous sauver la mise en deux
clics géolocalisez-vous dans n'importe
quel pays profitez de tous les contenus
et tarifs exclusifs lors de mes
déplacements professionnel en Belgique
impossible d’accéder au contenu france
télé et là nordvpn débloque tout
streaming film site de désolé j'ai
dérapé tout ça de manière sécurisée en
chiffrant votre activité vous pouvez
vous connecter en toute tranquillité à
des WC publics de plus avec l'inflation
il devient indispensable de faire des
économies préparer ses vacances avions
train hôtel et activités ça coûte
terriblement cher avec nordvpn comparer
les tarifs de différents pays afin de
profiter d'offres jusqu'à moitié prix ça
marche avec tout PC smartphone tablette
vous avez 30 jours pour tester si ça
vous plaît pas c'est satisfait ou
remboursé chez sciences trash on a
toujours un super cadeau pour vous
quatre mois gratuits en prenant
l'abonnement 2 ans si vous n'avez jamais
testé nordvpn avec les fêtes c'est
l'occasion de sauter le pas le lien est
dans la description ces ressources qui
vont disparaître on pourrait penser que
la terre ne sera jamais en manque d'eau
elle en est recouverte pourtant seul 3%
de cette eau est douce à peine 1,2 %
potable il existe ainsi qui recense en
temps réel le nombre de personnes qui en
manque c'est presque terrifiant de voir
à quel point ça monte vite on pourrait
penser que l'Europe et les États-Unis
sont les premiers consommateurs d'eau
dans le monde et bien même pas c'est la
Chine avec presque 600 milliards de
mètres cubes d'eau en 2017 à côté de ça
nos petits vintimilliards paraissent
acceptable 70 % de l'eau accessible est
utilisée dans les irrigations de
plantation les deux tiers sont
gaspillées par des tuyaux qui fuient des
mauvaises méthodes d'agriculture ou des
plantes qui en ont trop besoin faute à
un environnement adapté comme le coton
le riz ou la canne à sucre heureusement
pour nous l'eau est une ressource qui se
régénère elle s'enfonce dans la terre
remonte jusqu'à la mer puis s'évapore
dans l'air pour retomber et pour l'eau
qui s'enfonce trop profondément elle est
recyclée par les volcans en janvier 2022
oumga tounga a expulsé plus de 146
milliards de kilos dans l'atmosphère
l'humain peut aussi fabriquer sa propre
potable en la désalinisant sur le papier
c'est simple on fait chauffer de l'eau
elle s'évapore le souci c'est que c'est
très coûteux à grande échelle plus de
500 watts d'électricité par heure pour
seulement 1 mètre cube d'eau ça
n'empêche pas certains pays d'utiliser
cette méthode comme le Koweït et
l'Arabie Saoudite des sans nous faible
mais assez riche pour rentabiliser le
désacracènement une autre ressource qui
subit la surexploitation humaine c'est
les forêts à quoi ressemblait la France
de la préhistoire sûrement pas de vastes
chambelée c'était une forêt géante et
luxuriante que nos ancêtres ont décimé
brûlé découpés pour l'agriculture en
Europe de l'Ouest il n'y a plus que 34 %
du territoire qui est resté boisé
d'autres endroits du monde suivent le
même destin et c'est pas pour récupérer
du bois de chauffe ou de construction
non non les trois grandes causes de
déforestation sont la culture d'huile de
palme de soja et l'élevage de bœuf
chaque année si tu ne surface
équivalente à la Suisse qui est détruite
plus de 38000 km² pour ça on utilise la
culture du brûlis qui baisse la
fertilité du sol augmente l'érosion et
assèche le climat sans compter les gaz à
effet de serre si aujourd'hui le
problème est prise au sérieux et que
même des youtubeurs ont planté 20
millions d'arbres comme Mr Beast c'est
pas assez pour compenser les pertes à ce
rythme certains chercheurs estiment la
fin des arbres naturels pour 2319 ces
nourritures que tu ne mangeras plus dans
50 ans ça c'est la poire damso la
meilleure poire du monde vous ne pourrez
jamais en manger cette boire française a
disparu au XIX siècle parce que pas
assez productive elle est plus de 8000
autres fruits dont le goût vous sera à
jamais inconnu et ça va continuer le
prochain candidat c'est le miel 2021 a
été l'année la plus catastrophique en
termes de rendement il y a 21 ans on
produisait 30 000 tonnes de miel contre
9000 aujourd'hui la raison c'est la
disparition des abeilles depuis 98 les
colonies d'abeilles subissent un taux de
mortalité anormal à la fin de l'hiver
les ruches sont subitement vidées et on
ne sait même pas pourquoi on pensait que
c'était les pesticides on en a interdit
beaucoup et le problème persiste on
pourrait pointer les prédateurs aussi
comme le Varois un acarien d'Asie qu'on
a même importé en 1980 heureusement il y
a une solution le Timol issu de l'huile
de thym il y a aussi le frelon asiatique
un vol stationnaire à quelques
centimètres de la ruche une abeille
revient de son butinage et bam le frelon
la dévore et c'est un gros problème sans
abeille pas de pollinisation 80% des
espèces végétales en dépendent légumes
fruits cacao café faudra-t-il tout faire
à la main comme pour la vanille ou
utiliser des mini drone Polon selon la
FMI si on devait salarié les abeilles il
faudrait signer un chèque de 500
milliards d'euros par an actuellement
tous les pesticides dangereux pour les
abeilles sont bannis dans toute l'Union
européenne mais des nouveaux problèmes
pour y surgir aujourd'hui encore des
études tentent de prouver l'impact
négatif des ondes électromagnétiques sur
les abeilles et ça risque de piquer les
ondes de nos téléphones pourraient
brouiller les insectes et diminuer leur
énergie on estime la fin des abeilles
entre 2050 et 2100 si vous n'êtes pas
amateur de miel la disparition du
chocolat vous alertera peut-être un peu
plus un des aliments préférés des
français le Graal des enfants dans la
cour de récré une fin possible pour 2050
la cause de cette inquiétude la demande
largement supérieure à la production en
disant la consommation a augmenté de 32%
et ça ne risque pas de s'arrêter de 2014
à 2015 le prix de l'aliment était en
hausse de 9% le cacao est presque une
ressource de luxe dans certains pays
comme la Côte d'Ivoire ou le Ghana dans
les années 2000 le prix d'une tonne de
cacao valait 1000 dollars aujourd'hui le
prix a doublé il a même quadruplé pour
certaines quelques années comme 2012 le
problème c'est que le cacao est très
sensible aux températures un degré de
trop et il ne pourrait plus pousser en
Côte d'Ivoire et au Ghana soit 50% de la
production mondiale ajoutée à cela qu'un
cacaoyer a besoin d'au moins 10 ans pour
produire des fèves que pour planter il
faut déforester vous voyez le cycle
infernal couplé ses disparitions à celle
possibles du café en 20080 ou du maïs en
2050 et nos petits-enfants ne devraient
pas pouvoir goûter à grand chose
évidemment la science permet de
s'adapter chocolat de synthèse café in
artificielle on peut tout créer en
laboratoire mais ça ne sera jamais aussi
qualitatif alors voilà c'est badans hein
tu as envie de dire les stopper tout
mais c'est trop tard le train est lancé
c'est pas en insultant ta pote qui part
en vacances en avion que tu vas sauver
le monde juste retarder l'échéance de
quelques mois non la seule solution
c'est la science la société peut
s'adapter il faut simplement se pencher
sur ses problèmes et y consacrer les
moyens la viande commence déjà à devenir
artificielle le recyclage progresse de
jour en jour et le nucléaire annonce de
beau lendemain avec les projets de
fusion justement entourément aux
États-Unis ils ont la première fusion
nucléaire la fin des ressources ce n'est
peut-être pas la fin de l'humanité on
peut qu'attendre un futur meilleur que
demain car chaque épuisement est une
manière pour l'humanité de repousser ses
limites d'innover et de trouver des
solutions il ne faut pas succomber au
catastrophisme il faut juste savoir
économiser histoire de nous assurer un
temps nécessaire à l'innovation
[Musique]